the Joe Rogan experience where do you
draw the line when it comes to like
leather or different animals it's good
question yeah I I've gotten very very
interested in elephants you know in
terms of like their social structure and
what they're like and in learning about
how intelligence they are and how long
the memory is and I don't want to have
anything to do with elephant leather
like or ivory let's prepare a cue a long
time ago that had elephant ear as a wrap
okay
and I didn't think anything of it but
now I think yeah
that's my line I like they have elephant
wallets and I was like no I'm not
comfortable this here's your thing man
pigs are super [ __ ] smart pigs are
real sweet and when you domesticate them
like people have domesticated pigs that
lungs are well fed they behave a lot
like dogs the only difference being of
course if you fall on the Pigpen they
will [ __ ] eat you yeah and they got a
do ya often that have that's a very
common way for farmers to die they fall
in the Pigpen and the finally scraps of
clothes and like oh my god and just a
puddle blood my buddy but [ __ ] is left
there yeah so I know now thankfully
they're coming out with this kind of
synthetic food you know this and that
even these people know that mimics pork
or chicken I'm mimicking it's actual
chicken cells or pork cells yes yes and
that's gonna be a great day yeah that
brings me the the beyond burger that
people keep it cool disc because I want
to make sure this is true someone sent
me this I didn't have the time to check
beyond meat test positive for glyphosate
lets glyphosate glyphosate is roundup
masala this is very [ __ ] dangerous
they're trying to pretend it's not but
meanwhile they're dishing out [ __ ]
lawsuits when yeah yeah one couple got
was it two billion dollars I got a two
billion dollar ruling against Monsanto
another guy got five million it's just
it's a two billion because they got
cancer being pesticides I'm like yeah
maybe the I'll drink that's your bill
you got a good lawyers were there yeah
they're probably gonna lose and I mean
that seems like a lot of money yeah of
course but I was reading that that you
know if it's a it's a meat-based a non
meat based burger that's supposed to
taste pretty similar to me I haven't had
one
but what do I'm saying is now they
figured out how to take cells and
replicate right it actually is meat no
right but it's an equation as no animals
being killed right which is the ideal
she wonder if it's an it's dangerous for
you
but this glyphosate thing I need to find
out if this is correct that's dealing
reason why I brought it up I just
remembered and I think it's important
for people to have this is one of the
best things about that whole kind of
paleo Whole Foods situation no way if
you're gonna act in a certain way
towards your food know what you're doing
yeah I'd be happy to draw that line
about okay what are you comfortable with
and defend your decision yeah yeah what
what are you willing to kill you know my
friend Chris Pratt
oh yes hey he's got a farm like zone
thing that he does and he takes lamb and
you know he he puts the rod on their
head and yeah and puts him asleep and
they have no idea what's gonna happen
and then they just die instantly and he
made this like really detailed post on
Instagram about it and people got super
upset with them you know that he talked
about this as a peaceful thing and that
he has these animals that he loves and
cares for and you see pictures of him
like touching them and holding them and
then later they're packaged up as meat
and like but but you saw just a steak
you wouldn't have a problem with it
like if someone said look I cooked a
steak you'd get a lot of people like
whoo that looks good but it's like I
killed this animal and now I'm gonna
cook it
people like you're a monster everyone
has to other than getting hit by a car
some people have to put down their dogs
and their cats yeah so maybe this is not
and that lamb is being bred for that
purpose and it's being done painlessly
that's the important thing
and I'm sure that lamb had a good life
and it wasn't a factory crowded
shoulder-to-shoulder existence this
torture situation yeah I'm sure but it's
a very quick life you know lamb is a
baby sure lambs a baby but nature is
about us eating babies yeah I mean I
haven't had mutton I haven't had like a
sheep sheep you know that's such a
British thing and it's always like in
these old story books you read but like
now I don't think sheep get become adult
unless they're for their fur or their
hair well I've had wild sheep my friend
Remy Remy Warren he gave me some some
wild sheep backstrap it was very good
some wild sheep that he killed well I'm
gonna while I'm here I'm gonna try
hagfish have you had fish that's that
weird [ __ ] slimy thing yeah at the
bottom of the ocean how do they cook
that I it's Korean barbecue there's one
place here that has it I like it super
legit Korean BBQ yeah yeah yeah they're
cooking hagfish
yeah well I'm cooking it I guess
technically what does it like I haven't
tried it yet I can't wait what's the
reports uh not that good
I'm not surprised I like sign me up well
I like since I have a zoology background
I learn I'm like Noah but I want to eat
at two of every animal you know have you
had jellyfish yet I have it's tasteless
it's weird it's like plastic yeah it's
the sauce that has a chest yeah strange
I ate at a restaurant that's in the wind
yeah it's in the wind and it's the only
five-star Chinese restaurant in the
country or in North America it was
insanely good like you you realize like
wow it's true like you don't see a whole
lot of gourmet right like super high-end
Chinese restaurants what did you have
anything weird there yeah I had that I
had jellyfish sea cucumber had no I
didn't have that I had abalone that was
really that was not that a lot of times
it's like credit cards a balloon
it wasn't that yeah I've had abalone
before and I liked it I like it I don't
I don't love it it's expensive - what do
you got Jamie so from couple articles I
just found the the issue seems to be in
pea protein which is what is used to
make these burgers and article what I
found about what you were saying is the
impossible burger actually tested 11
times higher when tested for glyphosate
then they be on meat burger which is
there's two different versions I eat P
protein protein chips every day is that
a problem so there's an article I'm
getting some glyphosate what does that
mean good says P protein could have its
own concerns the detox project a
research organization looking into
pesticides of glyphosate that's been
looking into it for over a year it says
that there's there is an issue there's
harm we can hardly seismic lean protein
anywhere the results like those for
other products tested for the popular
pesticides aren't pretty it's a very we
can hardly find a clean P protein source
anywhere
Jesus Christ it's all got glyphosate
there's but I still don't know what
glyphosate does okay glyphosate this is
the idea okay and please google this
because the argument was glyphosate is
great because it just kills the weeds
and bacteria and it doesn't kill people
I'm gonna actually drink it well the
problem they're saying is no no you have
bacteria in your body so if you're
taking in glyphosate you're killing the
bacteria in your body it might not kill
you
sure but it's not good for you and it
[ __ ] up your system okay this is the
argument I guess that they use to
present in court they must have used
this to get the jury to award them two
billion dollars in damage cancer yeah
yeah that's not a monsanto parent
company bare feet faces thousands of
roundup cancer cases after two billion
dollar verdict thirteen thousand cases
right now yeah listen man this thing i
don't know see there's this is with the
problem first of all i'm a [ __ ] i don't
know anything about any of the science
behind this when i read this i see two
different cancer just like so many other
things yeah i see people saying there's
no evidence this is just they're all
hysteria but is that the people that
work for Bayer is that like their PR
firm that's putting this out there to
try to like alleviate people's concerns
and stop some lawsuits in their tracks
they try and do influence public opinion
on this or is there real science it
shows that this stuff is very bad for
you but there's definitely a bunch of
people online that are telling you that
it's horrible for you here exposure to
glyphosate base herbicides in a risk for
non-hodgkins lymphoma a meta-analysis
and supporting evidence I don't want to
switch off my P protein there ain't good
bro
hemp protein but that should get tested
too I'm what am I saying just start
eating steak I can't it's hard for me
that much it's problem bro do you know
who David Frankie I don't you know is
that his name hold on I'll send it to
you Jamie there's a [ __ ] hilarious
guy who is this big steroid up
bodybuilder dude that's also very very
funny okay and I see the one does the
bro science videos he's very easy for a
lie
always talking like this let me let me
find his is he gonna get me all swole I
sent it to these guys to the my I have a
fight companion Twitter feed that's
going I'm not Twitter feed text message
group text here it is okay Robert Frank
although say more yeah
it's I'm gonna send this to you do you
know what it is Jamie Robert Frank six
one five private it is oh no
oh so he's going to sign up oh it's one
of them deals because he says a lot of
crazy [ __ ] alright so how long does it
take okay hold on a second I'm gonna
text it to you right now how long does
it usually take for with those people
they have to be either one of those
dorks that sit in front of the computer
someone's doing it for ya yeah he must
have allowed me in alright I'm sending
it to you right now
BAM okay it went through do you go
through anyway
it's hilarious let's take that in post
it's hilarious there's no taking
anything no need no need to try to make
it smoother it's hard to put the
calories down though is my point
no it's not it's open your mouth chew
swallow oh yeah baby your grandfather
would have died for a steak like this
Jesus Christ listen to yourself
you're saying all the [ __ ] you would get
mad at people if they're saying about
any other subject it's hard it's hard to
eat all that food it's hard it's hard to
get by in this world it's hard it's hard
it's hard to get up every morning it's
hard I work hard I work hard how [ __ ]
hard is it to eat steak look at me bro
just eat it
cook it eat it put some salt on it
delicious maybe like some steak sauce do
whatever you got to do to get that steak
down your stomach sir get some grass
feed grass fed grass fed grass raised
it's got a darker richer taste it seems
like a lot of work grass fed no just
cooking steaks all the time
learn how to do it it's easy is it get
yourself a nice grill all right I'm in
Brooklyn though you're in Brooklyn you
got a yard
no no Oh Brooklyn come okay got a
cast-iron skillet I can get one that's
all you need it's not gonna stink up my
house yeah I'll stick up your house okay
mistake commands house okay
smell good people would be like tease
that Michaels living good
he's got the steak life he'll be
knocking on doors how about your box
bros are grass-fed let me just cut it
for me let me see what you got got
medium-rare oh yeah
kosher salt yeah well I got a kosher
chef it's the thicker so that's why I
use I like the pyramid salt what's that
it's shaped like a pyramid the crystals
really yeah they do it a certain way no
punch here if you're gonna cook a steak
like a man correctly you need kosher
salt okay
how many can how much grams a protein or
a steak a lot that's all you need to
know shut your [ __ ] mouth I follow my
macros every day well to put oh do you
are you really getting serious about
that I've always been because I have an
eating disorder so this is a way to good
direction okay yeah um you'd have to
look I mean it's it's certainly more for
wild game which is mostly what I eat
than it is for store-bought meat okay
but store-bought meat I would I would
guarantee you there's more nutrients in
grass-fed meat I don't know if there's
more protein that doesn't seem to make
sense but if you look at like it could
be more protein because they might be
less fat or whatever but more fat yes
that's - of course it would be more
protein if it was leaner yeah for the
same amount of ounces yeah but there's
also a bunch of other [ __ ] em toward and
essential fatty acids that exist and
grass-fed meat so it's all good stuff
okay let's get some steak and stop with
the pea protein bro
okay sorry protes I'm not eating your
people it might be [ __ ] you up man I
wonder I wonder how many people are
getting fun what are the dangers of
consuming glyphosate other than
non-hodgkins lymphoma maybe this is what
you're seeing over and over in people
yeah better not kill my gains there was
my game I think P protein is helping
your gains there's something about
knowing that you're getting all your
protein from Peas that's all of it some
of it makes you 60 grams MMA
what do you got - an endocrine disruptor
oh that's just no joke
that's what glyph is how thought liver
disease birth defects reproductive
problems in animals oh Christ what is
this from I just typed in dangers of
glyphosate I don't want to get them do
you I don't want to get a birth defect I
don't know what that is pull up whatever
us are TK is fine it might be horseshit
we should otherwise not argh us
Oh us right - no right - no hmm that
sounds mean anything like what is it
what is that based on is not look
Virginia look at that top news on the
right trial for Monsanto hometown it's
all Monsanto everything's Monsanto this
is just news story from today they're
all over the news right but you got to
be care this this is not real story
though look at all the top news is
almost like on their contact I bet you
it's just some it should have a some
dude GMOs are look what is it litigation
oh they're litigating this is from the
lawyers mmm could be yes I spend the
lawyers pushing for truth and
transparent yeah this is the lawyers
yeah the food system this is looks and
if there are two billion dollar rulings
you can just bet your sweet ass McFly
see [ __ ] people that are swarming on
this subject all right would be a better
source of information no nomads good
question what do we got here Alex let's
call Alex Alex Jill no he I don't know
he's up on food stuff he know about the
the plastic wrap that gives you raises
your kind estrogen you know the ones
that make southernxposure gay Scientific
American yeah okay that's good that's
good
2009 weed whacking herbicide Wow deadly
to human cells used in gardens farms and
parks around the world the weed killer
roundup contains an ingredient that can
suffocate human cells in a laboratory
researchers say yeah so we'll kill my
gains
yeah it's suffocating myself [ __ ] that
whatever that is whatever whatever has
that on it [ __ ] that stuff okay I'm
gonna go to more weight than just
carnivore die that's your move okay
I'd like Jordan Peterson